[Music]
we are on a roll sixteen hundred playing
crook for crook
b6 okay it's fine by me that's the owen
defense i don't think we've faced this
in the speed run thus far
um and there's obviously as with all
such openings there's multiple systems
uh that you can that you can play and
all of them give an advantage
but i mean
you should defend the e4 pawn whatever
you do so the simplest way of doing that
is knight c3
generally black plays e6 intending
bishop b4
and now there are again multiple
multiple moves uh multiple ways to get
an advantage here i haven't updated my
analysis in a while
but i do remember
looking at one system that i thought was
really good
and that is to play bishop d3 here
yeah and and here rather than going
knight f3
we do what
by the way a3 is a move here a3 really
is a move but it's a little passive
not knight f3 guys
knight e2
connect the knights
connect the knight so that when one
knight takes the other it's not the pawn
structure i'm worried about i'm not
worried about bc i'm worried about the
e4 pawn becoming a weakness
what now
well now we can either castle or if we
want to force things a little bit on the
king side
we want to force things a little bit on
the king's side
we can do what
not knight g3 no no no no
a3 yeah we can play a3 and force black
to take on c3 giving us the two bishops
i like the two bishops let's do it
obviously bishop a5 b4
and now
d6 okay this is pretty crappy
now we castle
now we've gotten all the all the all the
development stuff out of the way
i know a lot of you are thinking let's
play bishop g5 i don't love that move
i just know a lot of you are thinking
that
why don't i love that move because it
sort of shoots into nothingness and it
allows h6 bishop h4 g5 it allows black
to get his pawns in motion on the on the
king side
as i'll show you after the game
a move like that is highly overrated
if you were to develop the bishop i
would put it on e3 actually to reinforce
the center
um but if you want to be annoying here
if you want to be
you want to play this like a gm
there is a move in this position nobody
has said it yet
it attacks something it's a specific
move it attacks something zombieland you
deserve a sub
queen g4
in situations where you're anticipating
a kingside attack
a move like this can be incredibly hard
to face yeah so we've made black castle
and now very important not to play
bishop h6
because of what
if you're paying attention to details
it's okay i know you guys
all saw it
bishop h6 allows knight g6 intercepting
the queen and forcing the bishop back
now the time has come for the move you
wanted to play earlier
once again as we discussed two games ago
just because the move is ineffective in
one position doesn't mean that it's
always ineffective
now bishop g5 is a lot
a lot more annoying because h6 you play
bishop takes h6 okay we forced the queen
to move to e8
now we practice whole board awareness
what is the drawback of queen eight
let's think in a very like
in a logical way that seems useless
until it allows you to find the move
c7 weak the only person who said the
correct thing is is ham
ham jimmy c7 is undefended so from a
logical perspective you should already
be thinking of ways to attack it
okay and ip5 comes to mind well is it
really the case that black can't defend
that pawn that is exactly the case rook
c8 you take on a7 and then you return to
b5
otherwise black is pulled in 50
directions queen comes back you can
still take on c7
this is a very common idea in certain
openings like the king's indian
where
you're just very cramped right you're
just not able to
marshal your your forces to defend that
pawn
we went upon
now what's important about this move is
i didn't just fixate on the king side
okay thank you
one pawn to the good and our knight on
b5 is excellent
right it's just like
freezing everything
now it's time to slow down a little bit
right take your foot off the gas pedal
we're not going to mate him in the next
two moves
so let's just make some general
improving moves let's improve our
position
what does that mean well we can approach
this from several different angles
i love the mover yeah very good let's
let's start with ricky one we know we
won't go wrong with this move
because it also prepares a rook lift
now the moment the knight appears on g6
the first instinct that i have is to
chase it away with a pawn
first instinct that i have is to chase
the way with the pawn we can do so in
two different ways we can either play h4
h5
or probably what you guys are thinking
and we're gonna play we can play f4 f5
why is f4 f5 better
both of them are very good but
okay f6 yeah that's a good move
i mean that's why i personally would
have probably played h6 h4 because f6 we
have a diagonal for the bishop
but it's okay
um what should we do
we're still in great shape just
simple
only move
bishop h4 no need to panic no f5 is bad
five is bad i'll show you after the game
f5 is bad
e5 wow okay
good move our opponent is playing well
but um not well enough
now we can start worming our way into
whites into black's weaknesses
now i don't know how i saw this idea i'd
be lying if i said there was a logical
process i followed i just sort of
spotted
a way to win
material yeah bishop c4 check i guess
you could look at this because you're
supposed to look at checks
and every time a pawn is pushed what's
the drawback well it weakens this
diagonal doesn't it
and now that you played bishop c4 the
follow-up should be quite easy to find
thank you carnism
boom
let's get in there
oh i hope you haven't forgotten that the
bishop on h4 is sort of semi-hanging
but uh if knight h4 we play bishop takes
d7 finally we got him to think
aha but rook d8 defends the night but
he's forgotten about the c7 pawn we're
eating black alive here
okay but now we got to be very careful
right these situations people struggle
with a lot because
we've got like these pieces and they're
sort of
suspended in mid-air
we need to figure out a way to just
collect everything together
so
i love the move knight d5 we bring the
knight back to d5 and there's multiple
good moves we can play f5
but the point of this move is that
we're going to take with a pawn we open
the e file we x-ray the queen
and
yeah so this is where that's going to
come in handy and our bishop on e6 is a
monster
it's just defended by 50 different
things he's won a pawn back that's okay
we're not we don't mind that let me
think for a second
i have some cool tactical ideas i'm
trying to make them work
no i don't like rick takes f4 i'll talk
about this after the game
i don't see anything concrete although
no actually the sack is interesting but
i don't want to sack i want to play
more straightforwardly
let me think for a second how do we want
to do this
we can definitely sack and we'll
probably win
i have an idea
okay get out
get out
i'm trying to set up a mate which is why
i'm taking so long
now i'm thinking let's lift our rook
rook lift time rook f5 rook h5 i have to
speed up by the way
wayne takes h4
oh this is so close to being so
beautiful but ah there's no mate
oh
i'll show you some amazing concept now
the other rook let's get the other rook
in
i'm trying to mate him now black and
okay knight of fate
well defended by our opponent jeez
lift it
let's go all of our pieces on the king
side
more power
foot on the accelerator
rook
sneaks into h6 but our opponent is
defending it amazingly
i messed this up
i have messed this up pretty
royally actually
trying to mate but here's what we're
gonna do
we're gonna step back with our queen and
let the other rook into h4
got it
good
unfortunately after king h8 it's not
entirely clear how to proceed
but i have an idea
we have alakine's gun amazingly we're
threatening rook takes h7 so you guys
can see
and he misses it and gets mated
easy
fortunately i
i kind of lost my my internal balance a
little bit i got too excited by
combinations and so i started playing
unobjectively
who can tell me the fastest mate
but it works out in the end so it's fine
who can tell me yeah rook f7
boom boom
yeah our opponent played a little too
fast in the critical moments
kind of rolling
resigns
okay
good
so
yeah so the game's starting to get a
little bit more complicated you can see
we're playing 1600s
now this system is really really good
and i think that black
black is supposed to go knight f6 here
this is more flexible
and in response to knight ge2 black and
black doesn't have to go bishop before i
think d5 is the main move here
and then you get this type of
french-like position where c5 is coming
it's interesting you can check it out
bishop before is an inaccuracy because
it walks right into our concept
so a3
we got off to a great start castles
queenie queen g4 d5 we go e5
i mean just look at how passive and
crappy black's position is
remember the concept of getting the
queen out to g4
in general using your queen to poke and
prod for weaknesses is an underrated
concept from a distance the same goes
with queen b3 ideas
same goes with queen b3 ideas
and of course the ideal
move is g6 g6 weakens all of the dark
squares and it allows our bishop to get
into h6
so after castles we we're patient we
don't play bishop h6 we play bishop g5
now we identify the drawback and exploit
it
improve our position
this was a critical moment where i
started
losing my cool
now how did i immediately know that the
knight should be chased away well that's
just a common chess theme
that has occurred many times in my games
i've shown it before on stream
this idea of chasing the knight away
when it hits g3 or g6 just remember that
for instance
this game
what did i what plan did i execute in
this position with black to get an
advantage who can tell me
okay guys guys
how do you prepare h5 that blunders a
pawn it's not that simple you don't just
like
you have to apply the knowledge you have
to do a little bit of thinking
h5 has to be prepared
g6 that's right and the additional
benefit of g6 it creates an f5 square
for the bishop castles boom
boom
and then the knight is passive and we
take the pawn and we're in great shape
so this idea of kicking the knight away
from g6 or g3 is important because this
square
is what you know while the knight is
sitting here it's hard to get to black's
king
but i should have gone h4
i should have gone h4 because now the
bishop can be preserved i don't know
when to weaken the king and when not
well i've talked about this before not
all weakening moves are created equal if
you think about it h4 is not such a huge
weakness because most of the pawn
structure remains intact now if you
played g4 here yeah that would be a
pretty serious weakness but but the
other thing i always repeat this is like
you have to try to understand whether
your opponent has the capacity to
exploit the weakness in the next in the
near future
now sometimes this will backfire
sometimes you will say the answer is no
then the circumstances change and you
regret weakening your king that happens
to everybody even gm's nobody knows
exactly when it's okay to make such a
move but here i'm using
what i have the data that i have about
the position i mean look at black
species you see what i see i see very
passive discombobulated pieces
i see that my own pieces are all
clustered on the king's side that also
provides safety
does that make sense
the only reason f4 is wrong is because
the bishop now doesn't have any squares
we have to go back to h4
e5 was a great move by the way
but it allows us to infiltrate to e6
and somewhere around i think knight d5
was actually a mistake i honestly
thought
should have gone like f5 here i honestly
thought that we could sack on f4
and i'll tell you what i missed what i
missed was that after bishop f5 i
thought the queen is trapped
forgot the queen as f7
i thought black has to give the knight
away on e5 but i forgot queen f7 exists
queen takes f4 also is a blunder due to
g5 so
miscalculation on my part and therefore
we had to kind of start playing message
g3 probably another bad move because the
bishop on h4 is now stranded but at this
point i was falling in love with this
rook lift concept
and at some point i think if black had
played correctly even at the very end
i think if flacco's king h8 he's fine
it's very complicated but i think black
is fine here i don't see a way to keep
keep the attack going maybe bishop takes
that 5s to be played but this is
anybody's game
so i got overzealous here
i got overzealous and
shouldn't have given up this f4 pawn
and then g3 was another impulsive move
bishop g3 i think is a better idea you
know keep the bishop active
after knight g6 rookie four now your
threatening queen takes g6
now you're threatening this idea the
problem is that the way i played it
we're not even threatening queen takes
g6 because the pawn is going to defend
h5
you see what i'm saying
i wanted something like that but i
couldn't figure out what it was
here this almost works but the king
escapes king g6
there's just no follow-up why not rook
takes f4 and bishop g8 yeah there was a
reason
and that reason is queen takes e1 and
rook takes street black gives up the
queen for two for two rooks
and i think black is probably not worse
here so again and again any time you're
sacking a lot of pieces to win the queen
make sure
that you're actually counting the
material that your opponent doesn't have
800 pieces for the queen
very common mistake
in fact i made this mistake
many years ago i never forgot this game
i made exactly this kind of mistake
where i was like oh my god i found a way
with a queen i didn't realize that i'm
giving up like a kingdom and a horse i
was 1800 so i was already pretty good
scandy by the way didn't know how to
play against the skandy
so anyways let's fast forward my
opponent takes this poison pawn on b2
and in this position i find what i think
is a genius idea
knight b5
that's one sacrifice
i've already sacked two pawns here's
another one
and now rook a1 and i started
celebrating trap the queen i trapped the
queen
what did i miss what did i forget to
check for
he just takes on b5
then he takes on c4
and he's got three pieces for the queen
and a bunch of pawns and he's got like
look at his position he doesn't even
take the rook
he's just got
total domination
just look at his position queen can't do
anything here i have nothing to attack
meanwhile the pawn just rumbles toward
promotion
okay i want g4 like desperation but just
knight f8
no other pieces i can't attack with just
a queen
and and he destroys me
so
a good example of not
forgetting to check like how many pieces
i'm actually giving up for that queen
like 15
yeah pretty pretty awesome game by my
opponent you know it's funny after the
game my opponent told my dad um i was
obviously pissed
he was like i'm gonna keep the score
sheet and someday when daniel's famous
you know i'm gonna bring my scoresheet
to him
and uh
i was like rolling my eyes i clearly
remember this moment i was like all
right i'm never gonna be a gm so
just shush
and here we are
do i know his rating now well he's 20
he's still 2 000 i think
i think he's a doctor larry
all right
i was
nine that was nine
so but i think it's enough i think i
think at some point
as i'm having a great time but i have
some i actually have some stuff to do
before i go to sleep
i'll see you guys later
[Music]
you